bonsoir bienvenue très heureuse de vous
retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce soir
décryptage complet de la stratégie
militaire israélienne à Gaza avec vous
Guillaume Ansel bonsoir et merci d'être
notre grand témoin ce soir vous êtes
écrivain ancien officier de l'armée
française on a besoin de votre expertise
évidemment pour essayer de comprendre ce
qui ressemble de plus en plus à une
fuite en avant de l'armée dans l'État
hébreux euh le carnage humanitaire ce
sont vos mots la traque aussi des chefs
du Hamas dans le sud de l'englave cette
guerre totale est-elle sans issue vous
nous le direz tout à l'heure dans la
2uxè partie notre grand débat ce soir
France Algérie l'accord de la discorde
les députés les républicains ont échoué
à faire voter la dénonciation de cet
accord de 1968 qui facilite la venue
d'Algérien en France bataille politique
bataille diplomatique aussi à la veille
du débat sur euh l'immigration dans
l'hémicycle nous en débattons dans un
instant sur ce plateau enfin nos
affranchis ce soir le parti prix
politique de yelgose l'œil sur le
néérique de Delphine Sabatier et puis un
Bourbon expresss spécial en duplexe de
saint-toin où toute la gauche sauf
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est réuni ce soir ce
sera avec Marco Pomier voilà pour le
menu on y va Guillaume Ansel ça vous
regarde top
[Musique]
générique
c'est une bataille perdue pour la droite
mais qui en dit long sur l'offensive
qu'elle compte mener dans le débat sur
l'immigration qui commence ce lundi
l'accord francealgérie 1968 serait
dépassé immérité et injuste d'après les
ténors des républicains mais ils ne sont
pas les seuls à le penser le sujet
divise au sein même de la majorité et
Elizabeth borne a promis de renégocier
cet accord alors est-ce qu'il faut
montrer les muscles vis-à-vis de nos
partenaires algériens dans un bras de
fer qui nous oppose sur la question des
laisser passer consulaires ou préférer
la voix plus fée de la diplomatie
bonsoir belkir beladad merci beaucoup
d'être parmi nous ce soir vous êtes
député renaissance de Mosel vous
présidez le groupe d'amitié
francealgérie et vous avez voté ce matin
contre la dénonciation de cet accord
dans l'hémicycle bonsoir Michel Tabarot
bonsoir bienvenue c'est vous hein qui
portiez cette proposition de résolution
ce matin députés les républicains des
Alpes Maritimes enfin bonsoir Vincent
Vincent
je grand reporter spécialiste des
questions africaines et chroniqueurs
visage familier dans dans cette émission
Guillaume Ansel n'hésitez pas à
intervenir quand vous souhaitez je crois
que vous connaissez aussi le sujet donc
même à interroger no nos invités on
commence par planter le décor l'accord
France-Algérie en débat donc dans
l'hémicycle c'est dans le chrono de
blackco tout de
suite bonsoir Stéphane je me retourne B
bonsoir à toutes et tous à vous retourne
également pour écouter la chronique de
Stéphane bonsoir donc si les députés ce
matin ont dû se prononcer donc sur cette
proposition de résolution pour dénoncer
l'accord franco-algérien c'est sans
doute à cause d'une interview donné
début juin dans l'Express par éedouard
Philippe souvenez-vous euh histoire de
montrer qu'il était plus ferme que
Macron sur l'immigration il avais vous
proposé de remettre en cause cet accord
qui accorde un statut particulier aux
Algériens notamment pour avoir des
conditions de d'obtention de titre de
séjour plus rapidement pour faciliter le
regroupement familial à peine avait-il
dit ça qu'évidemment LR mais aussi Ren
criait au plagiaat puisque c'est une
mesure euh que de leur côté il
défendaient depuis quelques temps alors
faut dire que cet accord existe depuis
55 ans mais ça n'empêche pas qu'il y a
un bras de fer quasi permanent entre la
France et l'Algérie sur le dossier de
l'immigration donc tantôt c'est
l'Algérie qui ne délivre plus de laisser
passer ce qui fait qu'on ne peut plus
expulser les Algériens qu'on veut
renvoyer chez eux les fameuses UTF
évidemment de l'autre côté la France
elle aussi
c'est se défendre en ce bras de fer en
en supprimant en réduisant en fait les
visa sur les habitants du Maghreb et
donc notamment sur les habitants
algériens alors forcément quand LR
propose cette dépose cette proposition
ça fait écho avec la loi immigration qui
arrive bientôt donc c'est l'occasion de
rappeler que cet accord franco-algérien
68 c'est un traité internationale et
donc dans la hiérarchie de nos lois ça
vaut plus que n'importe quelle loi ce
qui fait que par exemple si dans la
future loi d'immigration on durcit les
conditions du regroupement familial ça
ne concernera pas les Algériens puisque
eux seront protégés par cet accord de 68
donc du coup du côté de la majorité bah
horizon forcément en cohérence avec
Édouard Philippe a voté pour certains à
Renaissance étent prêt à votép pour mais
le gouvernement a mis le oh là non on va
pas supprimer ce traité c'est Olivier
BCH qui était ce matin sur les bancs
pour répondre et en expliquant que si on
supprime ça a beaucoup plus
d'inconvénient que davantage on l'écoute
plutôt que de dénoncer l'accord et
d'aller ainsi droit vers une crise
politique diplomatique et
migratoire travaillons mesdames et
messieurs les députés au contraire à
l'amender alors de fait je prenais pas
beaucoup de risque puisqu'il répétait ce
que lesisabe B avait déjà dit dans la
presse ce matin c'est-à-dire que on ne
va pas supprimer cet accord on ne va pas
rendre les Algériens au droit ordinaire
mais en revanche elle prenait date pour
renégocier euh l'accord dire que
supprimer complètement cet accord est-ce
que c'est le bon moment parce que on
parlait des relations parfois orageuses
avec l'Algérie mais en ce moment ça se
réchauffe un petit peu bon le président
tboun a annulé plusieurs fois sa visite
mais là il dirait on a l'impression
qu'il va venir en France l'année
prochaine et puis regardez Géral Haran
lui aussi s'est déplacé début novembre à
Alger où il a pu rencontrer le président
tboun donc quand même une question
peut-on faire confiance au président
tboun et je dois dire que ce matin
Michel Tabaro a mis quelques réserves on
l'écoute faut-il rappeler qu'il a
préféré aller voir Vladimir Poutine qui
a qualifié d'ami de l'humanité plutôt
que de venir en France faut-il rappeler
qu'il a réintroduit dans l'yne algérien
couplé violemment antifrançais de façon
totalement honteuse faut-il rappeler la
suspension des laissés passer
consulaires et son refus de reprendre
ses ressortissants que nous voulons
expulser alors avant de vous laisser
débattre comme les représentants de
lesfi ne sont pas là avec nous ce soir
je voudrais quand même vous donner
l'occasion d'entendre leur indignation
celle qu'ils ont manifesté ce matin dans
l'émicycle c'est bastien Lachot honte à
vous honte à vous car les conséquences
de vos paroles sont graves elles
alimentent le climat anxiogène le
racisme et l'islamophobie qui étouffent
notre pays elles font le jeu de
l'extrême droite en accréditant ces
thèses voilà les grandes lignes du débat
sont posé les Algériens sont-ils des
étrangers comme les autres ou
méritent-ils un statut particulier avec
toute l'histoire commune franchement
qu'on a ensemble pourquoi merci beaucoup
merci Stéphane pour ce ce billet
parfaitement complet bel belkirbadad cet
accord il est ancien 1968 il a été signé
entre Paris et Alger 6 ans après
l'indépendance il est pas un peu dépassé
aujourd'hui faut d'abord expliquer que
cet accord a été mis en place à l'époque
à la demande des des Français parce que
notre pays la France avait besoin d'une
immigration économique importante et
forte c'est dans ce cadre et dans ce
contexte que ça a été mis en place des
ouvriers sur les chaners tout à fait
tout tout à fait et et c'est vrai que
cet accord est souvent pointé du doigt
depuis de nombreuses années avec tous
les tous les mots euh que certains lui
lui prêtent injuste injustement parce
que depuis 1968
euh en 1974 par exemple Debray sur le
regroupement familial avait freiné de
manière importante cette cette
immigration la mise en place en 1994
donc il y a eu des avenan c'est ça des
modifications il y a eu plusieurs avnan
il y en a eu trois il y en a eu en 84 en
94 et en 2001 qui ont systématiquement
euh restreint euh mis en place des
exigences beaucoup plus fortes en
matière de regroupement familial la mise
en place de présentation de passeport de
visa en 1994 mais c'est toujours plus
facile aujourd'hui vous le reconnaissez
notamment pour le séjour longue durée
pour le regroupement familial pour
ouvrir un commerce est-ce que je peux
vous prendre un exemple est-ce que je
peux vous prendre un exemple j'ai été
concerné par cette histoire là euh
puisque je me suis marié en
1994 j'ai mis 7 ans et pourtant j'étais
à l'époque pas français j'étais algérien
et j'étais concerné par cela et j'étais
concerné de très près par la guerre
civile en Algérie qui faisait rage et il
a fallu 7 ans 7 ans euh pour faire venir
mes enfants et mon épouse je ne crois
pas je ne crois pas que c'était que ça a
été un privilège la même chose pour
cette politique de visa qui été
fortement restreinte moi je pens visa
longe sé jours he visa notamment long
séjour et je n'étais pas le seul euh
beaucoup d'Algériens ont été concernés
par par cette histoire douloureuse et
euh et l'État français a mis en place
effectivement de manière discrétionnaire
à travers notre administration de
nombreux freins de de nombreuses
exigences qui ont fait que davantage
référence aux années de plomb aux années
noires le terrorisme que au passé
colonial et à la guerre d'Algérie pour
au fond garantir l'existence d'une forme
de particularité quand même oui tout à
fait alors pourquoi elle supprimer quand
vous écoutez belkir badade Michel
écoutez tout d'abord nous allons traiter
et nous avons traité cette semaine en
commission des lois et et la semaine
prochaine dans l'hémicycle d'un texte
qui vise à maîtriser l'immigration si on
souhaite maîtriser l'immigration on sait
pertinemment et bien qu'il y a des des
points sur lesquelles nous devons
travailler c'est la raison pour pour
laquelle les les républicains ont
souhaité déposer cette proposition de
résolution sur laquelle nous travaillons
depuis longtemps il y a d' d'ailleurs eu
de nombreuses études entre autres une
étude de de fond d'AOL euh qui qui
rappelle des éléments chiffrés des
passionnés mais qui rappelle et bien que
comme c'est un traité c'est un un
fonctionnement particulier qui fait que
que la loi sur l'immigration qui va être
votée ou ne pas voter le dans les
semaines qui qui suivent devrait
logiquement s'imposer et là comme il y a
ce traité entre la France et l'Algérie
il ne s'imposera pas aux Algériens à
partir de là il nous semble essentiel
premièrement parce que l'Algérie la
première diaspora en en France parce
qu'il y a 880000 algériens parce qu'il y
a donc un traitement sur le regroupement
familial et même si votre expérience a
été compliquée au niveau de votre
conjoint ça n'est pas le cas normalement
vous savez que c'est au bout de d'un an
de mariage qu'il a une possibilité de de
tire de séjour pour pour le conjoint
donc il y a des facilités qui n'existent
pas pour les autres et notre volonté
c'est justement d'avoir une maîtrise
totale de l'immigration donc ça passe
par un texte qui sera voté mais ça passe
aussi par cet accord qui aujourd'hui et
bien supplante le texte qui sera vot
j'entends bien sauf que pour l'instant
le texte immigration sur la partie on va
dire un peu
fermeté répression c'est plutôt renvoyer
les irréguliers qui n'ont rien à faire
dans notre pays plutôt que de au fond
c'est de V c'est pas ça aujourd'hui le
gouvernement propose une régularisation
des des de ceux qui n'ont rien à faire
sur le territoire voilà donc là vous
parlez des MTI en tenstion oui oui non
non non oui mais ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui le texte qui est
proposé on a essayé
de algérien en situation
irrégulière justement à travers ce
traité lorsqu'il reste sur le territoire
pendant 10 ans il a ensuite un titre de
séjour d'un an c'est quelque chose
d'exceptionnel ça ne concerne que les
Algériens Vincent eugu on voit qu'il y a
beaucoup de de politique hein et aussi
du du diplomatique derrière derrière
tout ça euh il y a beaucoup de tension
encore aujourd'hui entre entre les deux
pays est-ce que Alger avait les yeux
rivés sur ce qui s'est passé ce matin
dans l'hémicycle est-ce que même refuser
le fait de se poser la question de
dénoncer cet accord c'est vécu comme une
offense je prends un exemple très simple
récemment à Constantine la commission
d'historien co-présidé par Benjamin stor
historien français historien algérien
s'est réuni pour la 3oè fois il a été
recommander à cette occasion la
restitution de certains biens
symboliques de l'émire Abdelkader un
burnou un Coran une épée le lendemain
matin un quotidien algérien en arabe
avait titré l'historien français refuse
la restitution des biens h vous savez il
y a un député français Frédéric petit de
la 7e circonscription des français
établi hor de France qui a remis je
crois que c'était en septembre dernier
un rapport où il concluait dans ses
recommandations là encore euh il fallait
sans doute renégocier sereinement cet
accord de 68 donc je rappelle quand même
qui a été voulu par le général de Gaulle
bien renégocier sereinement on est quand
même un un cheveu de l'oxyort c'estd que
dès lors qu'il s'agit de la relation
tempétueuse post-coloniale entre la
France et l'Algérie rien n'est jamais
vraiment serein souvenez-vous l'Algérie
le vit cet accord comme une compensation
de la colonisation elle elle le vit
comme un droit souvenez-vous euh
Emmanuel Macron évoque en octobre 2021
la rente mémorielle oui d'un système
politico-mitaire algérien et cetera
alors j'observe simplement que la rente
mémorielle est un raisonnement qui
fonctionne sur les deux rives de la
Méditerranée je ferme la parenthèse
parce qu'il y a aussi une rente
mémoriale politique en France bien
aussitôt euh Abdelmjid tboun le
président algérien réagit en disant
c'est une insulte faite à nos martyres
et cetera ça donc oui il y a quelque
chose de de pavlovien là-dedans mais
regardez 2003 2003 sous Jacques Chirac
on parle d'un traité d'amitié
franco-algérien qu'en est-il advevenu
rien h 2012 François Hollande là plus
modestement une déclaration d'amitié et
de coopération elle n'ira pas plus loin
et puis 2022 Emmanuel Macron à Alger lui
parle alors d'une déclaration de
partenariat renouvelés donc on a beau
épuiser toutes les ressources du lexique
on on n'arrive pas à digérer ce passé là
notamment parce que et je termine
là-dessus il est parfaitement exact je
sais que le terme de rente mémorielle a
été jugé très polémique mais
que les trajectoires politiques dans
l'Algérie d'après les les accords dévant
elles étaient fondées sur la légitimité
FLN mais comme vous avez eu
effectivement des parcours politiques en
France qui étaient fondés sur la
légitimité de la résistance je pourrais
citer l'ANC de Nelson Mandela en Afrique
du Sud et cetera et cetera Guillaume
mansel euh on est on est là voilà à la
fois dans le symbolique il y a la
question historique la question
politique il y a un texte de loi qui
arrive hein c'est pas rien c'est
peut-être le plus le plus important de
de cette année 2023 après les retraites
est-ce que est-ce que les les la
diplomatie plus feutrée c'est le bon
endroit pour discuter de cet accord
plutôt que le Parlement vous avez vu le
tacle de d'Emmanuel Macron qui a très
clairement dit en conseil de ministrre
je n'avais pas compris que la politique
étrangère se décidait au Parlement pas
sympa pour les
députés ou moi je je suis frappé
peut-être aussi parce que par ailleurs
je suis directeur de la communication je
suis très sensible au creux et au
silence et j'ai l'impression que il y a
un fantôme dans ce débat qui est au
milieu de la salle et dont qu'il ne faut
quasiment pas évoquer tellement on a
peur qu'il ressurgisse c'est la guerre
d'Algérie en fait on on voit les
stigmates de la guerre d'Algérie qui
n'ont jamais été pensé ni du côté
français ni du côté algérien il se
trouve que j'ai parlé récemment avec
Benjamin Stora et Stéphane aoir rouso au
moment où historien spécialiste de la
enfin on arrivé à trouver une forme
d'accord avec le Rwanda pour dire voilà
on reconnaît ce qui s'est passé des deux
côtés et le président Macron très
courageusement a plié ce sujet qui avait
déjà 30 ans et dont tout le monde nous
disait vous verrez ce sera comme la
guerre d'Algérie on arrivera jamais à se
mettre d'accord tellement on a bousillé
notre relation avec les Algériens à
cause de de mémoire la France a présenté
des excuses pour le Randa pas pour
l'Algérie il me semble mais pas pour
l'Algérie et et ce qui est terrible
c'est que Benjamin storan c'est comme ça
qu'il nous l'a présenté il nous a dit en
fait ce que vous avez réussi à faire
avec le Rwanda c'est ce que je me
désespère d'arriver à faire entre la
France et l'algerdie c'est juste de se
dire on est deux générations presque
trois maintenant après la guerre
d'Algérie mais d'arriver à évacuer ce
sujet pardon évacuer n'est pas le bon
terme d'arriver à le penser et à le
penser avec un e d'arriver à dire quel
est notre rôle relation quelle est la
relation qu'on souhaite avec l'Algérie
un pays qui a été bien plus martyrisé
par sa guerre civile que par la guerre
avec la France et une France qui ne
supporte pas qu'on évoque le sujet
algérien sans sans lui faire reconnaître
que en fait c'est les Algériens qui ont
et je suis frappé moi j'ai beaucoup
d'amis algérien je suis frappé de voir
comme notre relation reste abîmée par
cette saloperie de guerre alors voilà
tout le monde veut parler Michel Tabarot
c'est important ce qui est dit là parce
que ça veut dire aussi que peut-être la
méthode n'est pas la bonne il y a
peut-être sur le fond une une vraie
question sur l'accord je trouve
exceptionnel quand même la
diom France B sa coupe à chaque fois
c'est-à-dire que tout ce qui vient de se
passer avec Monsieur tboun depuis qu'il
dirige le pays n'a l'air d'impressionner
personne ou d'agacer personne moi je
suis désolé lorsque Monsieur
tbou maintenant attaque le la langue
française lorsqu'il veut mettre dans
dans l'hyne national il veut remettre ce
qui était avant au niveau du du FLN qui
n'existait plus en demandant que la
France rende compte avec une certaine
agressivité lorsqu'il renvoie à la
France au mois de mars dernier euh le
les laisser passer consulaire en disant
qu'il n'a pas l'intention de de
dialoguer lorsqu'il laisse le
gouvernement français surtout le
président l'attendre pendant des
semaines et des semaines et qu'il et
qu'il se moque de lui en partant plutôt
voir son ami Poutine pour vous il
utilise le passé Coloni écoutez il
utilise parce que ça lui permet de
rester politiquement sur place ensuite
on a choisi monsieur Stora qui fait pas
l'unanimité alors peut-être que certains
l'apprécient ici mais qui fait pas
l'unanimité qui a parfois des propos
très désobligeants pour les Français qui
ont vécu en Algérie qui ne sont pas
responsables de ce qui s'est passé il y
a 130 ans je rappelle d'ailleurs que
c'était un socialiste enfin c'était les
socialistes qui avait décidé de la
colonisation et c'est vrai qu'il y a il
y a encore des tensions et qu'elles sont
légitimes je voudrais juste revenir
pardon sur prés la phrase Emmanuel
Macron je la trouve assez exceptionnelle
parce qu'il est très tolérant lorsque
les membres de sa famille am politique
présente des propositions de résolution
sur justement les situations
internationales et ne manque pas de se
positionner et tant mieux moi je suis
attaché à ce que on puisse à l'Assemblée
avoir quand même des débats qui
dépassent le franco français qui peutêre
pour ceux qui nous regardent que ça n'a
rien de contraignant on est dans le
symbole avec une résolbole et donc je ne
vois pas en quoi le Parlement
aujourd'hui ne ne pourrait pas évoquer
comme il l'a fait et bien ça accord
badade c'est vrai qu'après tout
ça gêne vraiment la diplomatie française
que au moins faire une résolution sur le
sujet il y a pas de tabou sur les
parlementaires ont le Dr pour moi il y a
un sujet il faut il faut le traiter
effectivement mais pas de cette manière
et et sûrement pas en
instrumentalisant ce ce sujet
et je je je je trouve que là il y a une
il y a une forme d'hypocrisie sur le
sujet on a on n'est pas là pour régler
des comptes avec le passé madame la ah
mais je suis pas là pour régler un
compte je je vous le
dis pris deçon très très il le faire de
manière dépassionné absolument d'accord
le groupe d'amitié que je que je préside
comporte d'ailleurs toutes ces toutes
ces sensibilités pardon j'étais j'ai
accompagné le président de la République
j'ai été échangé j'ai échangé avec le
président tboun qui m'a senti enfin que
j'ai senti vraiment très volontaire euh
sur sur le sujet très allant de vouloir
faire un un certain nombre de on l'a vu
avec ces dernières déclarations ces
derniers mois efftivement un certain
nombre d'actions mais il faut laisser le
temps au temps Madame d'ord et la
question il a accepté de traiter la
question notamment mémorielle qui est
extrêmement douloureuse pour les
Algériens vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
et la période notamment de la
décolonisation et la période de la
colonisation qui n'est pas du tout
traité et donc il a bien voulu accepter
à ce moment-là euh que effectivement
tout toute la période il son y compris
celle de la colonisation soit traité
dans ce comité alors là on est sur les
relations franco-algériennes au combien
tumultueuse et et passionnelle si on
revient sur ce traité est-ce que
renégocier c'est peut-être mieux que
dénoncer et en quoi faudrait-il le
renégocier d'abord c'est un traité
international il ne comporte pas de
clause de dénonciation ce ce ce cet
accord là et et donc il y a une
insécurité juridique à le dénoncer
aujourd'hui deuxièmement vous savez que
leor TER vous laissé parler madame ENF
ce sont des documents qui exist ensuite
c'est une prérogative euh du chef de de
l'État comme comme vous le savez et puis
ensuite le dénoncer euh aujourd'hui ne
réglerait rien par rapport au sujet que
vous évoquez tout à l'heure et les
problématiques qu'on évoque dans ce
projet
dez même de votre majorité mon pas moin
de de de d'Algériens qui demanderont à à
venir en français vous aurez vous aurez
vous aurez également comment vous
expliquer alors les divisions au sein de
votre propre famille politique les 25
députés horizon qui ont voté cette
résolution deux députés Renaissance et
et d'autres hein Astrid panoian Bouvet
par exemple cette députée de de votre
famille politique les macronistes
Renaissance voulit le faire elle ne s'en
est pas caché et puis ensuite nécessité
foi la la contrainte gouvernementale la
discipline emporté c'est bien qu'il y a
un vrai sujet non non il y a eu un vrai
débat au sein de notre groupe qui est
riche diverse comme comme vous le savez
avec des sensibilité euh très très très
très large et on a eu un débat là-dessus
et et donc on a on a souhaité
effectivement tenir cette position
plutôt d'équilibre j'ai aussi exprimé
mon avis là-dessus connaissant
effectivement la situation du côté
algérienne mais également française euh
que cette position d' équilibre
permettait justement de pouvoir avancer
c'est pas forcément dénonçant qu'on
arrivera à véritablement trouver à
trouver des des des solutions alors on
va essayer d'avancer vincentu un petit
mot puis je voudrais vous montrer un
sujet très courte observation Stéphane
leappelé tout à l'heure ce traité cet
accord pardon fêtera entre guillemets
dans quelques jours son 55e anniversaire
il a été évolu par Charles de Gaulle
alors certes il y a eu ces trois avenant
ces amendement en quelque sorte mais il
n'a jamais été dénoncé ni sous georgees
Pompidou ni sous Jacques Chirac ni sous
valallé giscardestin ni sous Nicolas
Sarkozi donc sans une nonce d'esprit
polémique on ne peut quand même que
remarquer qu'il y a là quelque chose qui
est de l'ordre de l'efféd domè puisque
ça vient à quelques jours de l'ouverture
de débat forcément ouleux sur la loi
immigration puis deuxième remarque et je
m'arrêterai là c'est que qu'on le
veuille ou non cette affaire est aussi
l'un des innombrables lèes de notre
aventure coloniale hm hm et on ne peut
pas dire comme ça zapper cette réalité
on on évoquait tout à l'heure
l'immigration qui avait été voulue à
l'époque hein pour la sidérurgie pour
l'automobile pour les mines et cetera et
cetera donc si vous voulez on nappelait
pas encore ça des métiers entention mais
la logique au fond était la même donc on
on ne peut pas qu'il s'agisse d'ailleurs
du Rwanda qu' s'agisse d'autres pays
d'Afrique qui s'agit de l'Algérie nier
ce qui est l'héritage parfois pesant et
embarrassant de ce qui a été une
aventure coloniale qui a été brutale et
violente alors vous allez répondre à
cette question du leg dans un instant
mais puisque vous dites que ça vient
percuter cette actualité parlementaire
au combien importante et bien on va se
poser la question après ce ce sujet de
savoir si finalement vouloir dénoncer
cette accord c'est pas simplement un
moyen de pression sur l'Algérie pour
obtenir les fameux laisser passer
consulaires d'autant que la facilitation
des expulsion c'est l'un des grandes on
va dire dimensions de de ce projet de
loi on voit cela là avec Marion
Becker le débat sur les expulsion
d'étrangers et les obligations de
quitter le territoire français les OQTF
a été relancé après l'attentat d'aras en
octobre en raison du profil du jeune
terroriste qui bénéficiait d'une
protection contre ses
qtf Gérald daranin en a fait l'un des
marqueurs de son projet de loi
immigration l'article 10 réduit ainsi le
champ des restrictions ou protection
contre les obligations de quitter le
territoire en cas de menaces grave pour
l'ordre public la situation familiale
l'état de santé l'arrivée en France
avant 13 ans ou la présence sur le
territoire depuis plus de 20 ans
n'empêcheront plus ces OQTF prononcés
par les préfets ce texte est très
important parce que il vise à pouvoir
appliquer euh ses ecttf moi je veux dire
dans ce débat sur les ecttf euh c'est un
débat un peu un peu fou puis qu'on
demande auur d'appliquer les eqtf très
bien d'une part plus de la moitié
d'entre eux sont soumis à des recours
donc on peut pas les appliquer l'utre
moitié la loi m'empêche de les appliquer
notamment la loi qui a été à voter au
début des années des années 2000
l'article 9 lui concerne les arrêtés
d'expulsion le projet de loi revient là
aussi sur les régimes de protection pour
les étrangers les plus protégés une
condamnation de 10 ans de prison pour
CRIM ou délit les rend expulsables pour
les moins protégés c'est 5 ans de prison
des interdictions de territoire français
des ITF seront prononcé ces mesures ne
s'appliqueront pas aux mineurs voilà
Michel Tabarot on bien comprendre on est
bien d'accord que l'accord
France-Algérie concerne l'accueil des
étrangers algériens tout ce qui concerne
les expulsions évidemment sous condition
de la loi délinquence double peine et
cetera pourra être appliqué pourra être
appliqué donc en partie en prenant en
compte qu'il y a le bon vouloir de du
président tbou donc pour le laisser
passer consulaire pour le laisser passer
consulaire qui permet de reprendre ou
pas les ressortissant donc pour vous
finalement cet accord c'est un moyen de
pression attention si tu me donnes pas
les laisser passer je déonce l'accord
accord il a été révisé vous parliez tout
à l'heure d'héritage colonial on pense
qu'on est on est 60 ans donc après les
accords des Viant on est 55 ans après c
ces accords qui ont été signés dans une
période vous l'avez dit très justement
où il y avait au niveau de l'économie
française un besoin de main d'œuvre
étrangère aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le
cas nous avons un grand débat dans notre
pays sur sur l'immigration et la volonté
de réduire on en est à parler de quotas
de plafond migratoires donc il y a la
volonté de réduire on a ce texte qui a
ça c'est les républicains pour l'instant
c'est ces motl ne sont pas dans le texte
du Gouvernement tout à fait on a on a ce
ce ce traité qui permet aujourd'hui qui
facilite l'entrée et l'arrivée des des
immigrés algériens et notre volonté donc
c'est de faire rentrer euh et bien ces
règles pour les Algériens à l'intérieur
d'un texte qui sera voté que nous
souhaitons que nous souhaitons voter
avec les amendements qui ont été mis en
œuvre au niveau du du Sénat euh donc on
sait pas si on arrivera à le à le voter
ou pas mais qui est qui est en parti là
puisque ce rejet en T tout à fait mais
mais que ce ce régime soit soit pris en
compte et que ce ne soit pas un traité
euh qui fasse que le la loi immigration
quelle qu'elle soit ne soit ne soit pas
euh en en lien avec avec ce qui va se se
passer ce qui est important pour pour
nous je crois c'est de de mettre tout le
monde sur le même plan et d'avoir euh à
part à partir de là un texte sur
l'immigration qui concerne les uns et
les autres et l'immigration algérienne
je le disais et la premère première
diaspora française donc ça concerne
énormément de de de concitoyens Belk
badade finalement c'est un levier un
levier de négociation ce cet accord
France-Algérie pour peser sur sur le
président tebou et obtenir les laisser
passer consulaires c'est c'est une vraie
question ça oui c'est un vrai sujet que
d'avoir un partenaire qui puisse
effectivement prononcer un certain
nombre de laisser passer je
constate que il y a une amélioration
dans
cette dans dans dans cette volonté de
donner plus de de de laisser passer par
que pendant le covid c'était zé he souvi
oui tout à fait mais c'était liée à une
problématique liée au contexte covoui
mais même après les mois qui ont suivi
ça a été bloqué totalement VO mais je je
le suis de très près je le vois le
travail qui est mené par le préfet de
mooselle par exemple et c'est le cas
dans beaucoup d'autres territoires avec
le consul le consul général de messe où
où il y a un dialogue permanent où il y
a des laissés passer pour un certain
nombre de de sortissant algérien donc ce
dialogue existe euh et il faut
effectivement l'approfondir mais c'est
encore une fois je le dis c'est pas en
le dénonçant parce que je pense que ça
créerait l'effet l'effet inverse
c'est-à-dire que nos amis algérien à ce
moment-là les laissez passer euh
consulaire ce sera zéro d'accord comme
d'ailleurs la coopération vous disz ça
parce que V votre premier ministre comme
nous avons laiss-moi terminer je vous
laisse je par jusqu'au bout laissez-moi
terminer vous voyez qu'il y a il y a une
volonté de de faire bouger les choses
que ça ne convient pas aujourd'hui
laissez-moi laissez-moi terminer madame
et et s laisser et s laisser passer euh
euh qui sont donnés par l'État l'état
l'État algérien sont sont en progression
les dénoncés seraiit contraireé bloqué
totalement en en mars vous avez de très
belles déclarations du président tboun
que vous appréciez et qui a tout bloqué
au mois de mars et s'il vous plaît et et
la coopération n'oubliez pas que notre
sécurité elle est liée aussi un risque
terroriste et nous avons une coopération
très édroite depuis de très nombreuses
années avec avec avec l'Algérie sur ce
sujet alors si vous avez envie de
prendre ces
risquesl de no con la menace du
terrorisme par
rapportord Franco Fran allez un petit
une petite question de la part de Guin
je n'ai pas compris de droit c'est
est-ce que le traité empêche l'exécution
des obligations de quitter le territoire
français non normalement non non non non
non non le le le tré limite l'accueil
limite
l'accue au même stade l'immigration
algérienne et les autres immigration au
même stade allez Vincent le mot de la
fin il y a peut-être une visite d'État
visite d'État du président de B oui en
c'est un peu l'arlaisienne quand même
croyz pas visite elle a été annoncée à
main reprise différée autant de fois il
faut être clair là-dessus si vous voulez
l'hostilité à la France reste un
gisement quasiment inépuisable de
légitimité pour un un gouvernement dont
la qualité en terme de performance
sociale notamment est loin d'être
incontesté y compris par les Algériens
eux-mêmes d'ailleurs merci on s'arrête
là on voit que il y a encore beaucoup de
chemins à faire merci d'être venu
débattre sur ce plateau vous restez avec
moi Guillaume Ansel dans une dizaine de
minutes les partis pris de nos
affranchis ce soir y el Go s'interroge
sur la stratégie présidentielle Emmanuel
Macron un peu loin du terrain régalien
Delphine Sabatier cinsurge contre ces
plateformes qui nous font payer pour
protéger nos données et puis un Bourbon
Express un peu spécial ce soir en
duplexe de saint-toouin avec vous Marco
pemier où toute la gauche se réunis sauf
les insoumis
oui myiam Saint-Ouin capitale de la
gauche ce soir les ténors de cette
gauche mobilisé contre le projet de loi
immigration du gouvernement un grand
absent quand même Jean-Luc mélch et son
étatmajor je vous explique tout dans un
instant à tout à l'heure les amis mais
d'abord on va s'arrêter sur la situation
humanitaire à Gaza avec vous Guillaume
mansel situation absolument
catastrophique l'opération militaire
israélienne a repris depuis une semaine
elle se concentre dans le sud du pays et
fait craindre le pire pour les civils on
voit cela dans l'invitation de Clément
perouau et on en parle juste
après si on vous invite Guillaume Ansel
c'est pour décrypter dans le détail la
stratégie de la armée israélienne dans
la bande de Gaza ses conséquences
humanitaires ses enjeux diplomatiques et
l'avenir de ce territoire Guillaume
Ansel vous êtes un expert en analyse
militaire ancien officier français vous
avez quitté l'armée en 2005 pour
rejoindre le monde de l'entreprise vous
avez publié plusieurs ouvrages sur le
Cambodge le Rwanda et
l'exyugoslavie aujourd'hui vous tenez un
blog baptisé ne pas subir où vous
proposez régulièrement des analyses
précises sur la guerre au Proche Orient
votre regard souvent très technique sur
les événements vous amène aujourd'hui à
des conclusions particulièrement
alarmantes les bombardements israéliens
ont éliminé 2 à 3000 miliciens du Hamas
pour 20 à 30000 palestiniens tués cela
s'appelle un
carnage 20 à 30000 morts c'est un
chiffre très supérieur à celui donné par
le Hamas vous l'expliquez par les
nombreux dommages collatéraux que font
les attaques d'Israël vous évoquez un
ratio d'un milicien du Hamas éliminé
pour 10 palestiniens tués dans ce
territoire très dense qui Gaza les
opérations ciblées de tsal peuvent
entraîner de lourd de perte civil hier
des troupes au sol ont pénétré dans la
ville de canyunes où se massent des
centaines de milliers de déplacés
elzitraak Yahya zinoir présenté comme le
chef du Hamas dans l'enclave ces
nouvelles opérations militaires
pourraient encore alourdir le bilan de
ce conflit dans vos analyses vous
insistez sur l'approvisionnement en
armes des Américains qui ne serait pas
éternel sur l'acceptation de la guerre
lourde par la société israélienne et sur
les risques d'escalade du conflit alors
ce soir on vous pose la question jusqu'à
quand la stratégie militaire
d'éradication du Hamas peut-elle
tenir réponse Guillaume
mansel pas longtemps pas longtemps pour
deux raisons la première c'est que cette
stratégie d'éradication va se heurter
sur le fait qu'il y a pas de résultat et
d'ailleurs on le voit au quotidien alors
que on est dans la 10e semaine de combat
2 mois aujourd'hui
exactement le Hamas continue à tirer des
roquettes presque au quotidien sur
Israël donc on a l'impression qu'il y a
quelque chose de vain quoi plus il
frappe sur le territoire de Gaza et plus
en fait on a l'impression qu'on
s'installe dans une logique de guerre et
on se souvient que l'objectif de guerre
affiché par le Hamas comme ils l'ont
raconté au New York Times c'est
d'instaurer un état de guerre permanent
avec Israël on a l'impression que le
Hamas gagne de cette guerre perman donc
pour vous Israël tombe dans le piège du
Hamas oui Israël tombe dans le piège du
Hamas parce qu'il y a une deuxième
raison qui fait que cette stratégie ne
peut pas tenir longtemps le poids de
cette mobilisation l'armée israélienne
c'est une armée de mobiliser ils ont
mobilisé 400000 hommes si on le rapporte
à un pays de moins de 10 millions
d'habitants c'est comme si en France on
mobilisait plus de 2 millions de
combattants ça Israël peut le supporter
quelques mois ou la société
israélienneut pas sour tout le monde a
un cousin un
frère voilà un père au com et ça ça ne
pourra pas tenir des Mo ça ne peut pas
tenir ça ne peut pas tenir
économiquement socialement d'ailleurs on
voit bien que les familles commencent à
dire mais attendez les nres là qui sont
partis se battre là-bas pourquoi et puis
enfin il faut rajouter un troisième
élément qui est important c'est que les
Américains soutiennent jusqu'à
aujourd'hui or les Israéliens n'ont pas
de stock ni d'obus d'artillerie ni de
bomb guidé donc on va y revenir parce
qu'il y a eu un vote important au au
congrès au Sénat américain notamment on
voit que les moyens militaires sont dis
proportionné d'ailleurs c'est assez
assumé ça fait partie de la la culture
militaire de ripost israélienne sa
doctrine mais vous qui êtes un expert
militaire vous regardez les images au
jour le jour des deux côtés vous dites
le nombre de morts n'est pas surestimé
par le Hamas mais au contraire
sous-estimé comment vous arrivez à cette
conclusion là alors d'abord je laisse
complètement de côté les chiffres du
Hamas on souvient que le Hamas quand il
a vu l'attaque de l'hôpital enfin le
bombardement pardon de l'hôpital Al ALID
av annoncé 500 morts alors que
manifestement sur les images on voyait
très bien que ça pouvait pas dépasser 50
morts et d'ailleurs personne n'est
réellement revenu dessus tellement ils
avaient
rajé ils sont pas intéressants ils sont
pour moi ils ne sont absolument pas
fiables ce que je regarde c'est parce
que je suis un ancien officier d'arttiie
c'est l'importance des frappes leur
répétition et les moyens qui sont
utilisés pour si vous voulez normalement
quand on vise quand on essaie de faire
une frappe dig chirurgicale on va
utiliser par exemple pour tuer un
milicien du Hamas on va utiliser un
missile le Fire dont dispose d'ailleurs
les Israéliens c'est un missile qui a
une charge militaire de l'ORD de 8 kg
quand vous sortez une bombe de 250 kg
c'est pas la peine d'avoir fait saincier
pour comprendre que vous allez faire 15
fois plus de dégâts donc vous ne tuez
pas deux ou trois personnes vous en tue
10 à 15 à chaque frappe quand vous
prenez le nombre de frappes et le fait
que il y a à peu près un/ers des
bâtiments de la bande de Gaza qui ont
été détruits ce qui veut dire qu'il
reste des corps dessous que personne ne
peut sortir tant que on n pas ramené la
paix personne n'a les moyens d'aller les
sortir ça veut dire des victimes civiles
qui meurent justement de l'effondrement
des tunnelû ça veut dire que on
sous-estime très gravement le niveau des
pertes et en tant que expert en
bombardement j'en ai mené j'en ai subi
des bombardements donc je pense savoir
un peu plus que les géopoliticiens qui
nous expliquent tous les matins que tout
ça est mené avec jusquà 20000 à 30000
morts mais c'est je sousévalue les
chiffres je dis aujourd'hui à ce stade à
2 mois de combat on est au minimum entre
20 et 30000 morts au minimum entre 20 et
30000 morts et quatre fois plus de
blessés ça VE veut dire qu'on a
largement dépassé le stade des 120000
Palestiniens victimes de cette guerre
c'est inacceptable surtout si on le met
au regard du bilan où les analystes
sérieux israéliens disent on a touché
quelques milliers de miliciens par de
carnage d'ailleurs hein et pas les chefs
qui sont au Qatar on va on va en parler
on va regarder la carte les combats se
concentrent à présent dans le sud du
pays avec à la fois des bombardements et
des troupes au sol de tsal dans la ville
de ragones le sud il faut le rappeler
quand même he c'était là où devait se
réfugier et les Palestiniens déplacer de
Gaza City vers le sud pour être plutôt
protégé c'est ce n'est plus évidemment
le cas est-ce que pour vous l'armée
attaque intentionnellement les civils
est-ce que vous dites ce sont des crimes
de guerre alors on est proche des crimes
de guerre je voudrais tout de suite
rappeler une chose que j'ai traversé
trois génocides il y a aucune intention
génocidaire pardon mais alors là c'est
vraiment des extrémistes quiess nous
expliquer que les Israéliens veulent
conduire un génocide non donc les
experts de l'ONU qui parlent de risque
de génocide euh là encore vous les
disalifier risque mais ils ont jamais
dit qu'il y avait un génocide certains
ont parlait de génocide d'ut de risque
risque pardon mais un génocide c'est pas
ça si les Israéliens se Metz à frapper
l'ensemble du peuple palestinien ils en
ont les moyens techniquement là on
dirait attendez là vous êtes dans une
intention génocidaire vous voulez
liquider un peuple c'est pas ça que font
les Israéliens ce que les Israéliens
appliquent c'est ce que vous avez
rappelé tout à l'heure c'est la doctrine
de ripost
disproportionné c'est-à-dire qu'ils
estiment que à partir du moment où ils
ont été attaqués l'attaque bestiale du 7
octobre qui avait été faite à dessin par
le Hamas et bien les Israéliens
s'estiment en drroit de frappé avec une
brutalité inouie je vais prendre un
exemple en drroit ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire simplement que ils sont ils ne
cherchent pas à minimiser le nombre de
victimes collatérales que les victimes
collatérales deviennent les victimes
principales on n pas dans le cadre du
droit international ou on est absolument
plus dans le cadre du droit
international et c'est pour ça que ce
qu'ils font peut être qualifié de crime
de guerre mais pas de crime contre
l'humanité ou de génocide il faut rester
dans un cadre objectif ce que font les
Israéliens est disproportionné quand
pour tuer un cadre du Hamas ils abattent
10 immeubles ce qu'ils font là n'a pas
de sens sauf que dans l'esprit de la
doctrine israélienne c'est montrer aux
Palestiniens que plus jamais ils ne
devraiit faire ça tellement les
destructions seront importantes les
conséquences c'est qu'ils n'ont jamais
donné autant de force au Hamas c'est ça
pour vous le Hamas a de quoi recruter
pour quoi une dizaine d'années une
quinzaine d'années vous savez ce qui est
très important quand on fait la guerre
c'est de ne jamais aller là où l'ennemi
vous attend or depuis le début le Hamas
mène Israël dans cette guerre qui en
réalité est une impasse j'oserais même
dire un tunnel hm hm il y a euh
libération qui a repris deux enquêtes de
la presse israélienne qui a publié des
papiers très intéressants sur l'outil
d'intelligence artificielle dans dans
ces combats ça pose la question aussi
justement de l'intentionnalité sur les
victimes civiles euh c'est un outil qui
permet de générer les cibles et qui dit
au fond voilà le calcul des des victimes
collatérales ça existe déjà dans dans
nos dans nos armées régulièrement ce ce
genre d'outil ça veut dire qu'au fond
tout est fait en connaissance de cause
alors oui tout est fait en connaissance
de cause mais attention l'intelligence
artificielle ne décide pas des cibles
elle les propose elle fait un travail
d'étatmajor accéléré les hommes qui
décid exactement là où il faudrait
normalement des centaines de personnes
pour calculer les cibles qui sont frappé
t jour l'armée israélienne annonce entre
200 et 400 attaques par jour en fait
pour mener 100 attaques il faudrait
pratiquement avoir 200 ou 300 personnes
dans des états-majors pour dire
qu'est-ce qu'on cible aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'on cible demain et là les
Israéliens ont multiplié par qu ou C la
capacité de frappe parce que en réalité
ils accélèrent leurs opérations ils
savent pertinemment contrairement à ce
qu'affiche tous les jours le le Premier
ministre netanahou qu'ils n'ont pas la
possibilité de durer pour les raisons
qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure et donc
ils veulent aller très très vite en
espérant obtenir des résultats tangibles
mais elle est un peu asymétrique quand
même cette cette guerre un état
terroriste un État démocratique est une
zone dense tellement dense que cette
banque de 50 km qui est Gaza est-ce
qu'il y a une alternative militaire
concrètement sur le terrain pas pour
demain pour après-demain aujourd'huiam
elle n'est pas un peu asymétrique elle
est totalement asymétrique c'est-à-dire
que les les comment dire les dégâts qui
sont commis aujourd'hui sont pr sans
proportion avec ce qu'a fait le mass le
Hamas n'a pas les moyens de l'armée
israëlienne et en fait le Hamas est
élevé au rang d'un acteur étatique
incontournable à cause de la politique
de netaniaou bien sûr qu'il y avait des
alternatives elles ont été étudiées par
certains Israéliens il y en a une qui
était absolument géniale qui consistait
à confier aux Palestiniens de se
débarrasser du Hamas notamment en
proposant des primes des primes
mirobolantes qui fait que ce sont les
Palestiniens qui se seraient chargés
d'aller éliminer le Hamas sachant que le
Hamas pour l'essentiel terrorise les
gens sur la bande de Gaza on on on
présente toujours ça comme si les
Palestiniens soutenaient à fond le Hamas
mais pardon c'est absolument impossible
aujourd'hui de faire un sondage moi les
amis Palestiniens que je connais ont
toujours dit il est pas question qu'on
s'exprime sur le Hamas à partir du
moment on a de la famille dans la bande
de Gaza h alors la stratégie de Salal
c'est aussi celle de l'encerclement
aujourd'hui c'est la maison de ya sinoir
l'un des principaux chefs du Hamas qui a
été encerclé alors il n'est pas
officiellement
a priori à Gaza mais les porte-paroles
de T disent que si il est dans les
tunnels alors est-ce que ça ça peut
contribuer à à décapiter le Hamas si on
arrive à à trouver à attraper leur chef
est-ce qu'on a déjà décapité un
mouvement terroriste sans que cette
personne soit immédiatement remplacée
tous les pays qui ont été confrontés à
des menaces russes la France au sel
chaque fois qu'on a annoncé qu'on avait
tué le Che chef d'ACMI le sous-chef
d'ACM pardon mais juste on fait de la
promotion interne et surtout on alimente
sans fond parce que c'est bien le
principe du terrorisme c'est de faire en
sorte que en frappant très fort sur
cette population on alimente les
volontaires pour le Hamas en réalité
plus on frappe sur le Hamas et plus on
le renforce oui donc ça ne changerait
pas la donne les Américains détiennent
la clé de ce conflit vous vous l'avez
dit il y a les élections américaines
présidentielles qui qui approchent et
puis il y a un y blinken qui retourne on
en est à trois fois déjà sur le terrain
et un Joe Biden qui commence à hausser
le ton il y a des sanctions pour la
reprise de la colonisation en
sisjordanie notamment sur les visas
américains et puis il y a ce vote au
Congrès alors c'est le Sénat qui a
décidé de bloquer l'aide militaire
d'abord sur l'Ukraine mais aussi sur
Israël ça c'est un c'est un tournant oui
c'est un tournant parce que en fait il
n'y a que les Américains qui ont des
stocks de munitions et d'armement
suffisants pour alimenter Israël et
l'Ukraine or tout ce qu'il aujourd'hui
consacre à Israël sera en moins pour
l'Ukraine qui va très vite être en
grande difficulté et d'autre part pour
Israël si à un moment les Américains
disent on arrête en fait dans les 3
jours les Israéliens faut de munitions
sont obligés d'arrêter donc on voit bien
qu'ils ont un levier très fort qui a
toujours eu un soutien très fort de la
communauté juive en aux États-Unis mais
la plus jeune génération c'est elle qui
dit mais à quoi sert cette guerre est-ce
que le fait de vouloir s'attaquer
militaire au Hamas va régler le problème
des Palestiniens et de la bande de Gaza
mais pas du tout ils ont très bien
compris que c'était une guerre sans fin
et sans issue alors comment imaginer l'
près c'est ma dernière question avec qui
avec qui il faut discuter pour le début
d'une sortie politique en fait si on
veut imaginer une sortie politique il
faut d'abord écarter les acteurs les
plus radicaux bien sûr austraciser
définitivement le Hamas on ne doit plus
parler au Hamas exactement comme on ne
parle plus à daesh au lieu de faire ce
que fait le gouvernement netaniao tous
les jours c'estàdire de ne parler que
deux et puis d'autre part il faut
écarter le gouvernement netaniaou qui
est au fond est le meilleur ennemi du
Hamas merci beaucoup merci Guillaume sal
revenez quand vous voulez je rappelle
qu'on peut vous suivre sur votre blog ne
pas subir vous avez beaucoup déjà de
followers comme on dit en bon français
et merci pour pour cet éclairage on va
terminer avec les affranchis vous allez
pouvoir réagir à leur partie prix on les
accueille tout de suite y Goose de
France Inter éditorialiste politique
dans cette émission tous les jeudis soir
et Delphine Sabatier de bmart pour son
œil sur le numérique bienvenue les amis
installez-vous on va commencer par un
Bourbon Express un peu spécial ce soir
avec Marco Pomier qui se trouve à stoin
c'est là et bien dans dans la proche
banlieu de Paris que la gauche mais la
gauche pas tout à fait tout le monde la
gauche sans les insoumis ont décidé de
se réunir pour se mobiliser contre le
projet de loi immigration vais comme Dom
oui myiam la nupese est morte et si vous
en doutiez encore et bien ce meeting en
cours actuellement juste derrière moi
est une preuve supplémentaire de
l'explosion de l'alliance des gauches
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est absent son
étatmajur aussi point de Mathilde
panneau de Manuel bonpard pourtant sur
le papier le rassemblement est large
toutes les sensibilités sont
représentées ce soir les socialistes
sont là les communistes aussi les
écologistes également et puis il y a
aussi certains insoumis mais attention
il s'agit des insoumis rebelles
traduction celles et ceux qui sont en
froid avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon elle les
nommé sont clémentineotin ou Raquel
garido elles sont présentes ici ce soir
donc il s'agit de faire cause commune
c'est ça malgré les les divisions
oui des divisions malgré les divisions
c'est ce que vous dites et pourtant ici
l'ambiance est plutôt bonne on a même vu
la gauche entrer sur les Black ipies et
puis les ténors de cette gauche et bien
ils sont tout sourire ce soir ce meeting
sert à se serrer les coudes expliqué
cyiel Chatelin présidente du groupe
écologiste à l'Assemblée la gauche veut
défendre une autre vision du projet de
loi immigration trop à droite pas assez
humaniste selon elle mais officieusement
ce meeting c'est aussi un moyen de
montrer une autre photo de famille une
autre union de la gauche alternative à
la nuupese Merriam enfin Marco comment
réagissent les absents ceux qui n'ont
pas été invités les
insoumis ah bah ils font griseem Miriam
en général on apprécie pas trop quand on
découvre que tous nos amis sont à une
fête à laquelle on n'est pas invité bah
pour les insoumis c'est un peu pareil
beaucoup ont découvert l'initiative de
ce soir sur les réseaux sociaux chez les
insoumis on trouve ça bien curieux hein
que Jean-Luc Mélenchon et son étatmajor
n'est pas été conviés à cette petite
fête alors que la France insoumise est
quand même le premier groupe de gauche à
l'Assemblée nationale alors on coulisse
on lâche les coups c'est dommage peu
élégant ça étale nos divisions me disait
un insoumis ils affaiblissent la cause
commune par des petites opérations
politicienne ils font fausse route je
cite en tout cas Myriam dès lundi c'est
bien toute la gauche qui fera front
commun dans l'hémicycle contre le projet
de loi immigration les écologistes
défendront d'ailleurs une motion de
rejet préalable du texte qui inquiète
beaucoup la macronie en tout cas cette
motion de rejet elle fait consensus à
gauche ou on va suivre ça évidemment de
très très près sur LCP merci beaucoup
Marco Pomier d'ailleurs demain grand
débat consacré à cette gauche au cas
Mélenchon que vous comparez je crois à
Cyril Hanouna de la politique et use je
vous ai écouté vous nous parlez
d'Emmanuel Macron ce soir plein emploi
export recherche innovation le président
ressuscite la startup nation au risque
de ne parler qu'à lui-même ouais Miriam
jusque là la cause était entendue
Emmanuel Macron il avait un point fort
incontestable c'était l'emploi le
chômage même plus peur or depuis la
mi-novembre on l'a vu ça se dégrade
sérieusement croissance molle ou nulle
chômage qui redécolle 7,4 % ça devrait
se confirmer en 2024 et ce n'est pas le
le surcis de standardin pours sur la
note de notre dette qui suffit à à
calmer les inquiétudes d'où le le
réveillez-vous qu'on a entendu récemment
lâché par Emmanuel Macron devant les
patrons d'où sa digression à Nant aussi
récemment aux Assises de la mer cette
métaphore du capitaine dans la tempête
qui redoublera d'effort pour atteindre
le plein emploi 5 % en 2027 tout devant
converger vers ce cap là alors que
voulez-vous dire et que l'angoisse de
rater ce bilan cette trace dans
l'histoire économique monopolise
peut-être trop son agenda retour vers le
futur c'est les accents de 2017 il faut
lever les barrières il faut secouer les
partenaires sociaux sur l'assurance
chômage des senniors il faut une loi
pacte 2 comme il y a une loi pacte 1 il
faut des électrochocs partout au collège
dans l'enseignement supérieur un acte 2
encore l' annoncé aujourd'hui pour
l'autonomie des universités on a une
semaine consacrée à l'export qui est un
autre maillon faible notre économie et
puis là maintenant il secoue la
recherche il secoue l'innovation des
scientifiques appelai la rescousse
aujourd'hui autour d'un comité installé
à l'Élysée et puis lundi à Toulouse ce
sera un coup de projecteur sur les
sociétés qui bénéficient du plan Fran
2030 c'est logique l'immobilisme c'est
une petite mort politique donc il bouge
mais attention à pas devenir émiplégique
ouis à condition de d'aller dans le bon
sens vous pensez qu' il passe à côté
d'autres enjeux importants le grand
danger c'est le l'aveuglement de type
Jospin 2002 la focalisation sur les
résultats macroéconomi économique et le
fait de ne plus avoir dans ses radars
les autres peurs les ressentis au niveau
micro des Français ce fut aussi le
syndrome matateo Renzi en Italie le son
qui vaut pour Macron faut relire la
tribune de l'écrivain que les politiques
français s'arrachent en ce moment
l'italien Giuliano da Empoli qui
ex-ceiller politique de renzy hein qui
écrivait ceci en janvier 2020 dans le
monde la vérité c'est bien l'amour c'est
mieux accumuler les chiffres n'est pas
très utile si l'amour entre un leader et
ses électeurs s'évapore c'est cruel
parce que ça veut dire que même au plein
emploi la défaite est toujours possible
parce que d'autres angoisses exagérées
ou non manipulé ou pas travaillent nos
nos concitoyens en particulier
l'immigration la pression est telle côté
RN qu'aucun échec ne sera toléré sur le
projet de loi d'armanin son examen lundi
vous en parliez s'annonce comme une
course d'obstacle périlleuse sans
garantie d'aboutir avant Noël or à Noël
il y aura ce sujet-là au pied du sapin
et à table autour de la dinde Emmanuel
Macron vous allez me dire est dans son
rôle il veut nous projeter devant
regarder devant par derrière la toute
dernière enquête de la Fondation
jeanores hein c'était hier soir vient
pourtant de le confirmer le retour
nostalgique aux trente glorieuses
constitue la société rêvée des électeurs
de Marine Le Pen passionnant etdito
Guillaume mansel il passe à côté du
régalien question
immigration sécurité il veut renouer
avec la ce qui a fait sa victoire il y a
5 ans mais on en est plus là euh moi je
suis un homme de gauche et et d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure quand on présentait le
sujet sur la gauche j'ai parfois
l'impression de plus savoir où j'habite
alors je suis content qu'un homme ait
voulu perturber l'équilibre politique en
France mais je suis frappé tous les
jours par la détermination du président
Macron qui un homme qui a vraiment les
objectifs qui se fixe va poursuivre
jusqu'au bout et son incapacité à
rassembler alors que au fond je crois
que c'est ça qu'on attend le plus de sa
part c'est une capacité à trouver des
compromis et à faire confiance peut-être
un peu moins dans son intelligence qui
est sans doute redoutable mais dans
l'intelligence collective or quand je
vois la manière dont il traite par
exemple les partenaires sociaux avec qui
moi je travaille souvent je me dis c'est
vraiment dommage de passer complète à
côté de cette capacité à trouver des
compromis qui font que de la CGT au MDEF
on vit bien parce que il y a des points
sur lesquel on s'accorde et tout le
monde va l'accepter et comme vous le
disiez très bienel la question c'est pas
toujours d'avoir raison c'est d'arriver
à trouver des raisons de raisonner
ensemble oui le père de la nation qui
fait des grands consensus on y est pas
encore on enchaîne avec vous dalphine
vous vouliez nous parler des des
différentes plateformes qui monille la
protection de de nos données et même
pousser un coup de gueule contre
Facebook et Instagram alors euh vous
payer ou vous acceptez en gros de vous
taire hein ça c'est le nouveau truc qu'à
trouvé MTA donc la maison derrière
Instagram et Facebook pour faire passer
la pilule du traçage publicitaire mais
surtout pour tenter de se mettre en
conformité avec le règlement européen
sur la confidentialité des informations
professionnelles euh personnelles pardon
dans le monde numérique euh je dit
tenter parce que pourquoi parce que en
fait je trouve que c'est une vaste
blague est en train de mettre en place
Facebook avec Instagram parce que
d'abord vous payez mais vous payez
combien vous payez très très cher
c'estàd que si vous décidez que vos
données restent personnelles et qu'elles
ne soi pas exploité à des fins
publicitaires et bien ça vous coûtera
192 € auamo à l'année voire 252 par an
si vous vous y preneenez pas très bien
juste pour un compte insta un compte
facebook donc si vous en avez plusieurs
la facture explose total allement donc
vous payez cher et en plus pour des
services qu'on a toujours connu
gratuitement c'estàd qu'on a une
habitude à utiliser Facebook insta sans
rien débourser demander cette somme
c'est un effort
considérable pour moi c'est presque même
rédiibitoire je suis pas la seule à le
penser alors si Facebook fait ça c'est
parce que ces pratiques de traçage
publicitaire sont jugé illégales
aujourd'hui en Europe qu'il a écopé
d'une amende très élevée mais ça ne va
pas suffire son payer ou accepter parce
que déjà l'organisation de protection
nos données qui s'appelle non of your
business he dont la signature c'est ma
vie privée c'est pas vos affaires app
porter plainte estimant qu'on éétait pas
face à un choix véritablement libre de
s'asseoir sur un des droits fondamentaux
dans le numérique de garder
confidentiell nos données alors
qu'est-ce que au fond ça rapporte
vraiment à à ma de faire ça il y a il y
a quoi il y a un manque à gagner pour ma
si ils ne font plus les publicités ciblé
si on les refuse alors c'est ce qu'on
pourrait se dire donc on se dit on va
faire peut-être le petit calcul combien
ça coûterait à méta si on ne partageait
plus no données avec ses publicitaires
donc si on regarde les les les derniers
chiffres qui ont été publiés par par le
groupe ils nous disent que un
utilisateur en Europe se rapporte
environ 16 dollars si j'extrapole sur
une année on est un peu plus de 60 € par
an on est loin quand même des 250 €
qu'on va nous demander de payer donc
c'est pas une histoire de manque à
gagner qui serait compensé j'imagine que
ma a plein d'autres exp
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est quand
même que ça met en lumière la valeur de
nos données pour ces réseaux sociaux ça
met aussi en lumière combien nous on
serait prêt à payer si c'était vous
payez o vous partez vous êtes prêt à
payer combien pour rester sur Instagram
et et Facebook quelle est la valeur de
ces résseau peut-être que ça va nous
montrer que bah c'est pas si essentiel
que ça finalement dans nos vies ça
montre aussi que les décisions qui sont
prises à Bruxelles ça crée quand même
des effets ça fait bouger les choses
mais quel temps passé parce que ce
règlement sur la protection des données
il a plus de 5 ans on en est encore là à
se dire est-ce que Facebook peut faire
ceci cela à porter plainte et puis
surtout on régule pas le marché parce
qu' on impose des règles d'accord mais
on n pas affaibli aujourd'hui les
bigtech on n pas vraiment bousculé les
cartes sur le mar on na pas repris le
contrôle véritablement mais c'est déjà
ça c'est déjà ça de voir que ça bouge
c'est c'est quelque chose qui vous
inquiète il y a beaucoup aussi
d'utilisation d'intelligence
artificielle de question de de
plateforme dans dans le mil militaire en
matière de défense plutôt que
d'inquiéter je crois qu'il y a beaucoup
de choses qui font espérer et en
particulier le rôle que vous avez évoqué
Delphine de l'Union européenne on se dit
que face à ces géants ce qui est
terrible c'est la dissymétrie de la
relation on voit bien quand on est face
à Facebook ou méta en fait notre avis ne
compte pas par contre quand c'est
l'Union européenne qui s'exprime et qui
menace d'amende en milliards d'euros on
voit bien que là les les géants de la
tech bouge parce qu'en fait ils ont un
acteur qui est crédible et qui a la
taille et c'est là où pardon mais je
pense que au 21e siècle ma génération a
loupé ça et c'est au suivant de le faire
c'est que c'est au niveau de l'Union
européenne qu'on trouvera la force de
discuter avec des acteurs majeurs alors
que on voit dans nos débats français
qu'on se voit encore comme une grande
puissance alors qu'en réalité on est un
pays moyen dans un ensemble qui compris
je crois qu'on a compris quand même que
il faut être 27 pour faire face à G ni
Facebook je suis un peu boomer mais du
coup je payerai rien d'un c'est pas
c'est encore possible ok bon on verra si
ça tient ou pas merci les affranch et
merci à vous guum d'avoir été notre
grand témoin ce soir c'est la fin de
cette émission demain on reviendra donc
sur ce meeting de la gauche même lieu
même heure très belle soirée
documentaire Jean-Pierre gracien à
[Musique]
demain